welcome to this video guinea Oh from the
US I have a good score answer kuba and
FMS okay cool so we have this kind of
variation yeah I'd like to play this g6
set up this a bit risky but but it's a
bit more interesting than the classical
variations there yeah this is all played
very quickly i know but i want to i try
to be a little bit quicker and if its
opening stuff that i know i just play it
quick and cut a little bit on the
explanation yeah the long line and this
is well known it's it's supposed to be
between equal and a little bit better
for white but i never really thought
that this is anything much and if white
is not going for that like it's normally
quite ok hmm it's a surprising decision
i would think that II 5v5 looks a bit
weak here isn't it ok let's see
no maybe castling lon not sure rookie
eight
luke t 1 I will take the pawn so that's
not going to happen now I thought Bishop
f4 actually would be a bit better okay
can play rook e1 or so but the night
before maybe being greedy yeah so he
went back Luke h5 is a move to check
this pawn even more but hmm not clear if
it helps much can even go G for them
kymco f6 this is a very simple solution
I don't like to I'm not what I'm not
sure about is if he goes look to you one
next step and then this have less kind
of freakish so let's do this it's maybe
not the best line but it seems some
seems okay gets my bishop actor oh
really I not expect that one I thought
94 would be fine ok let's go there
now probably a lot a lot of things i
equal him to be honest Bishop e3 for
example looks very equal ish after the
trade no it's not doing that ok ok win a
tempo here yeah so do i want to play
something like look at five and getting
the center there hmm difficult difficult
to judge its kind of uncommon but maybe
maybe it sets it's okay
yeah uncommon means I've been giving him
the outside passer but quite active so
maybe that's it still okay b3 I guess
and d 5 rupee one is the critical line
yeah I wonder if this is any good there
there's no way not to trade not really
check my bishop is really nice on this
diagonal it looks at those h8 promotion
square but it's still probably really
really Jewish what is he doing that
going to e3 maybe maybe I is preparing
you for okay
yeah that not ending in a draw would be
quite surprising
quite sure yeah i mean i have the
drawing hand i think if he takes not
sure if I'm having any winning chances
2x 2x King 2335 can be to see three
that's not not going to be okay that's
nothing nothing I think it's really just
a draw and you anyway to try to win this
probably not
Jim what can you do it just a draw draw
our third game drawn kind of do the
pointing effort as nothing is probably
always a draw him I don't know maybe
like computers Ted thinks we should be
five is still something I didn't see
that I'd really didn't see that this is
a possible re i can I'm kind of not
believing that I really have something
great here but that has better chances
then in this end game which is just a
draw this this may be a move that's a
bit more interesting each form p three
steaks Kingda to it's still a draw it's
probably really just a draw what can you
do thats nothing going on there yeah
just one word about the opening and here
I black has a number of classical ways
to try mostly he can play this which I
ever after takes takes 93 / should be
795 is quite dangerous for him and g6 is
an is an interesting deviation now now
I'm d5 is critical and after the takes
takes takes white um here he can has a
number of options white can also play
this move which is interesting leading
to shower play or what he did with but
as I mentioned what he did I think is
it's not leading to very much this is
very equal dish
so Oh a computer wants to Castle short I
did not think about that one yeah I'm a
bit better developed so maybe just short
I did not think about that with the open
age phone had that threatens 94 I think
I had this before I had this before on
the board and I forgot about it 94 is
the goodness is the idea maybe against
the same player as possible really
should remember that that castling here
is good with 94 being a threat okay well
thanks for watching